are you writing anymore like theater
play uh no I'm I'm I'm going to be
starting something I'm next next uh next
year I'm going to phase out touring and
really begin to write a write a new play
and write a book that's really what I
wanted to which you've done before I've
written three books in a lot of plays
and that seems like very see I like the
theater because even though I'm not
really personally because I have so much
anxiety a people person but it does
force me to get out writing a book or a
play seems incredibly insular and
Incredibly I would get into a very dark
place does it not when you're just
focused on that does that not no because
you're in another realm if you're really
you know either because partly it works
as part of the reason I wrote was to be
able to say stuff that I wasn't saying
in my act that I had other things to say
that I'm not a just a joke Pony here's
what we're doing here's some other
things I have to say about life
um and that's kind of what I want to
write again which is mostly a combo of
really trying to summarize what the [__]
I've been talking about for so many
years because of that I would think that
uh and it's kind of like what uh Billy
Crystal did with like 700 Sundays I
always wanted to I always thought that
you and and even more when I was looking
into stuff when you when I knew that you
were coming on because you have the
ability to pop in and out of whatever is
prepared I thought that you are an
amazing I mean that's what stand-up
comedy is but maybe a more um uh built
oneman show Lewis Black on on on
Broadway where you talk about whatever
the world is but there can also be
really produced you know uh audio visual
enhancements and sets and maybe even
bringing in another actor and you know
look you know I I don't know what that
is have you ever thought about something
like that no but if you're willing to
invest um I can start work on it
tomorrow thank you
I just heard a little
Wisconsin I always know when he's gonna
laugh he brings that Wisconsin
up just a touch of oair um but no you're
the first one I've talked to about it
and so you could be right on the bottom
that's very I mean I've I've certainly
thought about it I I wanted there's a a
book that I wrote that I'm I'm trying to
turn into that one man show because even
like I always thought like even though I
thought of you as being uh very Pol a
lot of political Lil I always thought of
you like if you had other actors on
stage what would you say to them about
what they did you know or what and which
brought us to whatever today is I just
think and because you come from that
world of being able to write a play and
create a character you are a character
you really are but I always thought that
that would be I was amazed that you were
writing plays and just presenting them
and not being in them yeah no because I
partly because going to Y um was the
actors I met the one thing when I got
there was like I mean I got to do a lot
of acting because I've learned a lot
about when I was there as much about
acting as I did about playwriting and
and the actors I was working with were
tremendous so it was kind of like I can
find somebody who can do a better job
doing this than I can you know but
nobody can do a better job writing you
than you right which is why I was trying
to write this the one that I've got it's
it's funny when I write a play it's like
I take myself out of
everything